voilà vous l'avez reconnu invité de
notre journal jean louis trintignant
l'un des interprètes d'un très beau film
l'instinct de l'ange que vous pourrez
découvrir après demain sur vos écrans
c'est l'histoire résumée d'un jeune
homme qui pendant la guerre de 14 bien
que tuberculeux et donc en principe
réformer tient absolument à apprendre à
voler pour participer au combat aérien
à force de volonté cet homme interprété
par lambert wilson y parviendra mais son
exigence morale va l'isoler de plus en
plus de ses camarades d'escadrille tout
de suite un extrait
bien au chaud c'était moche fonce et
brouillonne capitaine
[ __ ] c'est votre poche
non non pas aujourd'hui suivaient pas
refroidir tu peux me trilles et vos mots
capitaine pour colonel vous voulez bien
motorisé prenez le moral biplace avec
guerbert à l'égard d'air comme
mitrailleur aux arts du canada
merci messieurs c'est ce jeune homme
revient vainqueur il ne sera plus jamais
humble jean louis trintignant suis très
heureux de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau vous avez une très très bonne
formule vous avez dit c'est un film qui
vaut le haut c'est une belle formule
c'est vrai c'est un film qui rend
intelligent c'est un signe dans ton sort
vraiment exalté intelligent je crois
c'est un film sur la différence sur la
difficulté d'être différent oui c'est à
dire que dans un groupe quand quelqu'un
est trop doué est trop fort il n'est en
péril l'équilibré du groupe
alors c'est vous à tf1 voilà on est à
france 2 mai donc c'est votre problème
on l'a vu vous êtes le colonel enfin
vous êtes le chef de cette escadrille
vous avez beaucoup de sympathie pour ce
pour ce héros mais votre problème c'est
la cohésion du groupe et l'exigence
morale de ce héros mais en fait en cause
l'existence du groupe et il va finir par
cristalliser toutes les ressentiments
oui c'est ça je veux pas tellement
parler de mon personnage sinon que c'est
pas un vrai militaire c'est un militaire
mais à cette époque là les gens qui
faisait qui servait dans l'aviation
pendant la guerre de 14 n'était pas des
aviateurs c'est à dire que le corps
d'armes des aviateurs n'existait pas il
a existé plus tard c'était des gens qui
venaient d'autres d'autres armes
certains étaient tirailleurs et ce qui
était passionné par la vie l'aviation
avaient été réunis dans un groupe et a
été des aviateurs c'est à dire que
c'était un type des marginaux dans
l'armée voilà est-ce que vous adhérez à
l'affirmation selon laquelle quand on
est un petit peu trop différent des
autres
renvoie les autres à leur médiocrité on
cristallise un peu en quelque sorte oui
c'est terrible à dire mais c'est la
vérité absolument cocteau a dit une
phrase très jeune et il a dit pour
établir l'égalité il faut couper toutes
les têtes qui dépassent
c'est terrible mais c'est vrai j'ai lu
dans une interview à me dire si c'est
vrai ou pas vous aviez une blonde
conversation avec l'un votre fils et
voulait bien un petit peu de tonus
discours à savoir tout le monde ne peut
pas voler sur les six mais il faut
savoir assumer sa différence voire sa
médiocrité dans le sens du terme c'est à
dire j'ai pris les choses un peu dans le
sens contraire
mon fils ne voulait pas être normal il
voulait être exceptionnel comme beaucoup
d'enfants c'est très beau d'ailleurs
comme beaucoup d'adolescents c'est très
beau je trouve ça très beau mais enfin
le c'est vrai je lui ai dit un peu le
contraire je lui ai dit il faut que tu
assumes la médiocrité alors qu'il n'est
pas particulièrement médiocre mais pas
du tout même on peut peut-être dire un
mode du metteur en scène richard gbagbo
qui est un homme tout à fait atypique
dans le milieu du cinéma puisque son
dernier film qui était tout à fait
extraordinaire la diagonale du fou date
de 80 ou même c'est très très rare un
metteur en scène qui est qui met huit
ans pour faire un autre film où ça
arrive quelquefois quand les metteurs en
scène non pas de succès mais lui a eu un
succès énorme
il a eu le l'oscar à hollywood du
meilleur film étranger
donc ils avaient toutes les possibilités
qu'il voulait pour faire d'autres films
et il a attendu huit ans pour faire ce
film c'est quelqu'un de très très
extraordinaire de très doué d'ailleurs
je ne sais pas s'il n'est pas trop doux
et même pour rentrer dans ce milieu tout
dernière question je suis très content
que vous recevoir parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour vous vous
faites assez rare alors question toute
bête pourquoi outil peu de présents sur
les grands écrans on vous propose que
des rôles qui vous intéresse pas ou vous
voulez personnellement prendre de la
distance surtout ça bah oui parce que je
je me suis réveillé à 60 ans en disant
enfin peu avant même qu'ils appelleront
tant que c'est 60 ans mais je me suis
réveillé en me disant il faut quand même
prendre le temps de vivre
je crois que on n'est pas obligé de
passer à la télévision pas vous c'est
votre métier
mais moi on n'est pas obligé de passer à
la télévision qu'on parle de vous pour
être heureux je crois même que ça rend
pas tellement heureux une aujourd'hui
contre l'ambiance du tournage ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui vous manque tout
de même non non je m'en doutais bien que
plus la région que ce soit chaque
tournage que ce soit un bonheur mais il
faut aussi être très exigeant je crois
si on veut que ce soit un bonheur voilà
on profite beaucoup des choses quand
elles sont rares alors définition merci
beaucoup jean louis trintignant un
projet tout de même vous avez d'autres
d'autres projets une pièce ou un autre
film voyez cette année je vais faire une
pièce de théâtre et je vais jouer dans
deux autres films
merci beaucoup s'il faut pas aller les
films avec qui qui sauvent ce qui est
pierre goux pierre boutron boutron
pierre boutron pardonnez moi j'ai pierre
outre ans merci beaucoup de gaz il avoir
été notre invité je rappelle pour nos
téléspectateurs que vous ils pourront
retrouver les dialogues de ce film qui
sont tout à fait super dans un bouquin
qui